some current events what do you got sure
yeah shout out to hockey
if we can convert you to hockey
i'm trying okay so over in dallas there
is
a restaurant that is known for modern
day comfort food
and it's a black-owned business who
primarily caters to
a black clientele you make like soul
food yeah they make soul food like
elevated soul food
and there is a clip of the restaurant
owner going off on his patrons and it's
mostly women
he's basically saying if you're gonna
twerk in my restaurant get the [ __ ] out
because i guess they were playing megan
the stallion there was
a group he was telling me it was the
restaurant was playing megan the
stallion yeah would you what do you
think
i hear that i start twerking that's the
second thing
you have to shake your ass
the same thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i will snap my dick
a little bit getting a little rowdy but
it doesn't seem like they're bothering
anyone but this restaurant owner saw
was super mad goes off on them saying
like this is why black people can't have
nice things
he goes off he's black also though he
just wanted to clarify
thank you guys into developing this
concept so black people can have
somewhere nice to go
to okay somewhere where we can feel good
about ourselves
does he have a short he tells his own dj
to stop the music there with short
sleeves on
it looks like it yep can i tell you
75 of our customers are ladies and i
want me to show respect for themselves
for how they carry themselves here
so how can i tell the men to respect
themselves and you guys are talking
about last year if you want to do it you
[ __ ] out my restaurant oh wow
yeah [ __ ] but but hold on this is his
restaurant
he has a point but that get the [ __ ] out
was kind of like we were talking
we were talking sopranos earlier this
guy is the black artie bucco
yeah he ain't having it i love artibuco
too but
this guy doesn't know what he's doing he
[ __ ] up
in the fact that listen he in that clip
he told his own dj
shut the music down yeah he brought the
dj
and paid him to be there but also to
play make the steps that's what i'm
saying
which you hear with the stanley cup
shake your ass
it's something right now i got good
do you think that the guy just did that
to get exposure
no because this is not awesome no no
because the younger audience are never
no people are mad about this
yeah but this guy [ __ ] up his yelp
reviews i bet are awful now like this
ain't the look man
he had to make an apology of course
now if they were twerking to like
beethoven or something
yes like i wanna just say his point like
you're gonna play that like
he wants a fine dining restaurant
experience but
he still employed a dj to play meg the
staff
he said no he says no caps no slides no
tank to i agree no slides
don't wear those shoes
no cussing no jerseys no sacking pants
you know what he's saying no sweat suits
white people do you know what he's
saying no black people yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you're black no that is the realest [ __ ]
ever because that is so true anytime
like what club
clubs yeah yes clubs are like new
jerseys no jewelry zoom in back this is
the first line that you know it's not
not for black men no baseball baseball
caps casual
headwear no durex yeah they put them on
their ex i couldn't go in there look at
me
look at me i'll never be on the jumper i
have kicks on i
had on a jeweler damn i couldn't go in
that restaurant
so you want to have me in your
restaurant no he don't want you that's
what he's saying he don't want you he's
that's the polite way of saying can't
have black people and you're a black
owned restaurant that's so messed up and
i support blizzard he's tyrone bigham's
but also
he also doesn't go full throttle in that
realm because he's then employing a dj
to play that music
thank you he has his
own hang up still like he can't go full
one way or the other
so he's like you know he's a torn man i
think he's yeah
i think he's confused he's a narcissist
and he also says be respectful
anyone who's breaking these rules be
respectful when informing a guest that
they're not following our
dress code when he went
take that [ __ ] somewhere else yeah yeah
get the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ] out of my
room do we have any [ __ ] you also
have a short sleeve
turtleneck john i have so many questions
that is i thought he had it rolled out
i think he thinks he was being polite in
that moment yeah i'll tell you this once
the food's popping all right who cares
see what i'm saying that's what he did
there
all right all right tonight
whatever you call me crackers
popping crackers i'm getting a sea bass
i'll come in there with a tuxedo on it
hell yeah my hair party call me a
cracker dog wait what's his restaurant
called
true food which is also that's a chain
no no no i know what you're talking
about foods and kitchens
like that there's another part to it
true food kitchen
yeah i believe not getting any black
celebrities you ain't getting anybody
i'll tell you this i go to dallas i'm
going you're going i'm going i got to
try it out now
you're going to twerk i want to see that
[ __ ] minion don't play make this
stallion i won't shake my ass dude
that's the thing that's on you that's
how you are employing the dj you play
some diplo and you don't expect me to
take my shirt off
yeah play some elevator music at a low
level if you don't want people to twerk
oh man you can just tail oh dude you can
just tell that the roster
yeah that's the owner yo what's that
mean you like wait hold on go to that
chicken [ __ ] let me see what that's
hey bring up the menu
okay
how dare you tarnish this
how dare you do you see this uh southern
fried nashville hot or asian hennessy
dude
take your twerking somewhere else you
ratchet huh
bro he sells fish for 13 this is some
reasonable prices right here
yeah right chicken and waffles it's got
a wide
section dude look at the waffles butter
pecan
cinnamon roll peach cobbler wait what's
moed yo more wet champagne
that's [ __ ] in the special dessert
peach cobbler seven dollars
come back and cheese shrimp and grits
pudding dude [ __ ] those twerkers
he's so stupid
what the [ __ ] is going on right now
suddenly
[Applause]
it's bomb oh i bet it's so good look how
you serve but that looks like small
i don't want the small proportions
that's why it's thirteen dollars i got
small that is dude that's a lobster so
yeah it's like deep fryer's attitude
that's like perfect like for deep fried
food
we're just doing a show it's it's
between i figure it's in
texas it's between santa are you gonna
stop by i'm trying to see how far that
is yeah
who's this oh far from san marcos
san marcos san marcos i think that's uh
i don't know
wait what what's there it's it's
literally i think san marcos i go to
that
it's between austin and dallas literally
austin and uh san antonio
it's literally in the middle oh oh my
god that's what coming in twerking hold
on now
no they ain't twerking they're they're
okay so if you promote
damn oh she's like works
you think they allow white people hold
on i think she said
i think that's the demographic you know
it's funny if they didn't allow white
people
we would just be like you're right that
like makes sense yeah yeah yeah
that's him right there with the girls oh
that's his girl no no
i think she's doing her only food show
on the internet she's doing like a
review of it yeah
i'm jade the chevron grits
i think you want to snap your mama
there's a table back here y'all
but beyond the food we've got phenomenal
drinks here too we've got dreams that
catch on fire
we've got i don't want that yeah
girls who go to dress up have dinner
with their friends yeah sounds like my
place some of the type of place you
should
get away with working every now and then
yeah also don't do that maybe like on a
wild night or something yeah on a wild
night a saturday night also don't do it
yeah don't [ __ ] this up for us man
okay okay you get a little i wonder if
he's gonna allow me and okay
damn that place is lit i want to go [ __ ]
dude
i want to swing and make this fried
pickles
yeah it looks like fried pickles pickles
and fries restaurant dude
he did get trashed for doing this
twerking video but i am honestly i've
never heard of it till he got trashed
and i'm on board see that's what i'm
saying
for that me and you though i don't think
he was i don't know if it was that
involved but
look at those chickens i know they're
like fancy waffles
oh my god they're miniature waffles yeah
you can dip it in there
small as hell i'm not gonna lie to you
anyway he can't even finish a meal at
chick-fil-a
[ __ ] you know what maybe he doesn't
want you there malik what about that
yeah how about she do wait who's that i
don't know
does he post outside daddy's is oh my
god
they're not gonna they're not gonna post
the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
check out the foreheads
what else you guys got how about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son